game of clones how do you arrested any
kind of fluid without some sort of nose
plug sure if you're conscious you can
breathe mouth only but when you're in a
deep expositional flashbacks unconscious
sleep all nasal bets are off a few
people said hey i really like that scene
with waves and rise of skywalker then
disney said we should include some high
waves in the book of boba fett even
though it does nothing for the story but
remember berries be cray cray yo
reminding us attack of the clones exists
look i love return of the jedi as much
as the next person who was seven years
old in 1983 but even at that young of an
age i knew the three stooges-esque
offing of boba fett was idiotic so one
thing i never needed to know when they
brought him back in mandalorian was how
he got out of the sarlacc pit i don't
care how he got out of the sarlic pit i
don't want to be reminded he was ever
put in the sarlacc pit you don't have to
retcon and answer every [ __ ] question
star wars leave your stupid mistakes
alone we were all just happy boba was
back
[Laughter]
now they're literally using the patent
oswald filibuster scene from parks and
rec as a direct script for this part i
mean we literally made this joke when
boba showed up in mandalorian so we
can't quite give you a sin-off if you
let us of all people beat you to a joke
but still this is some top-notch
self-aware fan service looking directly
into the
suns this helmet removal makes the
classic star wars decompression sound
effect on release but boba jammed an
oxygen tube in there while escaping the
sarlacc so that seal's already been
broken mr sound design man even in boba
fett's current state getting bested by
jawas will always be a sin
and that little bit of floppy carrot
worm semen will be all the explanation
the show needs to get from basically
dead in the sand to able to walk for
miles behind a bantha in a driving
sandstorm scriptwriting this is starting
to feel more like dune than star wars i
hate it when people mix their dune in my
star wars what's next lady jedis episode
takes 6 minutes and 41 seconds to book
of boba fett taking robert a heinlein's
name in vain
younglings
how are they even drinking that i grow a
mustache and i have trouble getting
liquids into my mouth without making a
mess they basically got the grill of a
1934 brewster town car to sip through
we're almost 10 minutes in and the show
still hasn't given us a single line of
dialogue and yet the storytelling is
compelling and strong any wall-e or
anything but it's still worth it off of
the sin-off cap
tattletails alright finally some action
it's been over 10 minutes of nothing in
they're just gonna circle around each
other for a minute aren't they fun
also this stocky walkie darks on for all
the i can't see what's going on here
time boba took several shots to the face
in that last fight and unless they shot
this scene at the old beach i can't
figure out why his facial lacerations
have already healed also i know this
entire opening takes place in the
flashback to chamber and we're dealing
with memories or dreams or some [ __ ] but
the show is clearly using it as
expositional foundation so the sins all
stand plus here's a few more for
questioning me in the first place wake
up boss boba here's this no one will be
allowed to pause for a restroom break
during the boba slowly has droids help
him get his various pieces of armor in
place seen shall i kill him fennec isn't
killing me in this scene i do not taught
you cause i'm a good guy now would you
be loyal to me if i were to spare you
this is a bad idea fenik would be
fantastic at tv sins even if they do
conveniently come in handy later i'm not
enjoying soft dumb boba fred over here
wearing this much armor in the heat more
like boba sweat am i right
i'll leave quietly they're used to
seeing the huts paraded around the
streets being tasked with the job of
transporting jabba the hud around town
on a litter would you like your homeless
service and clean while you wait for
madame garcia no turning down getting
your helmet serviced what oh get your
mind out of the gutter i'm just saying
helmets get pretty icky you pervs ah
sudden flash dance if i may nope you
finnick that was a different show that
disney owns you must be thinking of
and now they throw these agents with
shields at her it's seriously like
they're taunting her with it here's 10
cents for disrespecting aos like that
where were these two chekov's deus ex
gamoran as the last few minutes
twiddling their giant green thumbs this
is by no means the worst fight scene
i've seen in a star wars property but
still results in a couple of minutes and
nothing special shooting your enemy in
the back
then why the hell didn't you take the
other guy alive instead of blowing him
to pieces are those throwing stars did
this get recorded over with a 1985 canon
films release i'm not even complaining
i'll take a ninja 3 the domination right
now over whatever this running across
rooftops nonsense is
[Music]
i love phoenix so much another full star
wars minute of slowly walking through
the desert if the show's gonna be 67 fat
flashbacks fine but can they be at least
a little more interesting than this
constant under the tuscan sun walking
through the desert were there no walls
to paint or floors to be waxed anywhere
how is this discount goro even seeing
through the sand to make these precision
grabs and why is tetratum sandler coming
out back first when just seconds ago we
saw all four arms reach out as if they
were face up also when did he let go of
the rodian and why none of the actual
geography or linear progression of this
moment makes any kind of sense and why
else would we love star wars other than
geography and linear progression holy
[ __ ] he just got his chest bundled so
hard he went a foot and a half into the
sand below him have you ever pounded
sand that takes so much force there's
like a whole saying in everything magic
chains magic chains auto grab anything
you throw them around this beast is kind
of fun but these are the times i wish
people like stan winston and ray
harryhausen were still around they could
have made this creature 10 times cooler
looking in their sleep
taking credit for other people's
achievements
[Music]
underpaying on your boba debt this
ill-fitting glove one full minute of
footage that was probably so expensive
to film disney felt it could only be
justified by including it in multiple
episodes opening doors like this isn't
efficient make a tiny door in the big
door everyone knows that what were your
orders um was killing him not obvious i
mean perhaps there'd be some confusion
if the assassins dropped in out of the
sky covered fett and margarine pulled
out pan flutes and farted pennies out of
their asses while circling a cauldron
but they you know tried to kill him so
why is question well if he's not gonna
speak
he no longer needs his head fortunately
the nightmare pumbaas here interpreted
fett's order in this non-lethal way
instead of committing to the actual
decapitation that they could have easily
assumed he meant overpriced you're
paying for the name i'm sure more than a
few disney execs said something very
similar in 2012. their reputation is
legendary there is no way this one will
talk yeah well i've got a rancor-shaped
plot convenience that says otherwise
earlier i saw the ornate grade on the
floor and i thought to myself man how is
anyone going to peer into this rank or
pit to see the victim below but now i
realize the show's just going to change
the dimensions of the bars for maximum
cinematic effect it's empty you said
disappointing let down for fans around
the world wrong call me picky but when i
was promised a galaxy far far away i
wasn't expecting 90 of my time to be
spent on the same dusty planet populated
by over-achieving sand castle builders
the excessive amount of gamorean gays in
the filming of this tv show was not
something i was expecting this area here
is restricted restricted but not locked
go to garza's sanctuary yes blindly
follow the suggestion of the individual
that you still strongly suspects in
assassins to kill you where's admiral
ackbar when you need him you haven't
heard now flip isn't exactly playing the
pronoun game here but rather it's
closely related cousin the referencing
an important development so vaguely that
the main character has no choice but to
ask a further clarifying follow-up
question instead of just telling them
what we all know you're eventually going
to tell them anyway game title probably
needs some work before we pitch it to
darth ravensburger the twins
have laid claim to their late cousin's
request yes we're getting a crossover
with that bonkers star wars visions
episode with the crazy mech suits and
ow
turns out that the drummer hearing is a
block away beating in open air and is
super tiny like the size of my ass now
when you see the drum you may think wow
the tv sims narrator has a big ass and
maybe i do but as far as drums go it's a
small drum and it shouldn't be heard
from that far away do you ever stop and
look at the creatures of the star wars
universe and then create a short list of
possible reasons why it could need its
hairy chest covered in tiny bikini
triangles is the fabric protecting sun
sensitive hairless skin perhaps it's a
fashion choice a dare or highly
offensive nipples that society has
deemed too inappropriate on a female
because it may or may not cause someone
to think about something sexual and
that's obviously her body's fault
somehow this is a [ __ ] painted water
butt i'm sorry but i was expecting my
2022 star wars show to have production
quality slightly higher than doctor who
circa 1971. you can bring as many
gladiators as you wish
but these are not the deathbeds of der
and i am not a sleeping trend ocean god
this is i'm sure a very impressive
retort to anybody who has the first
[ __ ] clue what either of those things
are isn't it super convenient that
fett's memories are shot so
cinematically through a series of
dramatic camera angles here's a
confusing part of the story where a
train goes by and kills a whole bunch of
people and then you come to find out
that they didn't really need to be shot
if they'd have just stayed away from the
train line breathing in tuscan dead skin
cells
title of my tuscan sex tape
vet walks into a fight in progress and
the speed bike gang instantly grabs
their weapons as if they know he's there
to kick their ass why did no one assume
phet was there for a brew or maybe to
play that nifty bar game why the force
did fed even bother bringing the shooty
stick instead of mowing these fools down
from the interest he fires one shot and
then uses it as a glove until it breaks
why not lead with the actual beady stick
if that's all you're gonna do i think i
saw a sign calling this the one at a
time bar although at the time i thought
it was referring to the number of drinks
you can buy not a handy pre-warning
referring to how you can expect to be
attacked this
makes it go this makes it stop this
stops and goes on for all the drivers
that i'm out of the never-ending desert
of please vader get on with it sometime
like a panther
yes no stop it that is a badass fed is
trained that is fit that needs to cover
his face to protect him from the sand
the end lever pulling graphics aligning
nozzle twiddling excitement
character stands still like a brainless
muppet instead of actually watching out
for a very obvious danger cliche that
cordy stick must be made out of super
heavy gordy wood to not instantly fly
off the train at such a high speed are
you carrying spice we appear to have an
off-worlder coming to the rescue of an
indigenous group of desert people
wrapped in tension centered around an
ambiguous but highly sought after spice
why dune does this dune sound so dune
familiar dune now travel under the
protection of the tuscans
but just these tuscans right the
internet tells me that the tuscans are
made up of disparate tribes that cover
vast amounts of desert and rarely number
more than 30 to 40. how can that
guarantee anyone's safety all the way to
anchor head if you know what screw it i
already know far more about tatooine
anthropology than anyone ever needs to
[ __ ] what they must have known this
was the water card and they're just
going to let ninety percent of it spill
into the damp desert this is some
absolute bantha sh
[Music]
a gift why i mean is that that clueless
he just killed the train and gave them
massive scavenger supplies a gift is the
least the tuscan should do
nope nope nope no thank you noob no way
i am not looking noob
oh wait i have something for this skip
previously on one of these star wars
prequels that i'm still not going to
rewatch no matter how much you try to
force it down my cannon that's nasal
passage survives this they finally give
him some head protection and the second
he steps outside into the blazing suns
he takes it down is he determined to
keep his dome as sunburn as possible at
first i thought this double trained on
for some time which was sort of fun but
also long then i thought it tripped on
for some time but now i realize this
episode actually sundial woods on for
all the some time judging by the fever
dream one must go through and the hours
of intimate woodworking one must do i
think it's safe to assume that these
staffs carry a deeply symbolic and
personal meaning for their owner which
makes it all the more ridiculous that
this whiffle snapped his just so that
all of this water could be wasted
wait what happened to the a plot we were
with the ocean's raiders of the tatooine
express for so long i could be forgiven
for forgetting about it entirely but
that doesn't mean the writers should
have as well
thank you previously on for showing us
that we should expect an unfetched night
rest random shot of spider droid thingy
is random until of course someone in the
comments explains to me politely how
meaningful it is to the overall story it
might even spin a web of evidence to
support their claim
i'll leave quiet quietly i was concerned
that you would feel insulted why would i
feel insulted zero clue but i don't know
how we'd even know if you were temura
morrison has the exact same facial
expression with every line he delivers
after the sail barge disaster there was
a power vacuum bib fortuna assumed
jabber's mantle this entire scene is
helpful so helpful in fact that one
would assume the debrief would have
happened long before now also is the
names bib mos espa trained oceans
aqualish clatunians and mokshas are
thrown out i realize that we've been too
hard on movies like raya and the last
dragon sure spelling all their
exposition out with pretty visuals was
annoying at the time but i much prefer
that to this absolute mind-boggling
storm happening in my brain they have a
visual map right there make it light up
or something add a banner with district
symbols that match up to the names show
me a hologram face for [ __ ] sake mayor
has no power he certainly does he has
the wavy hand sweet talking court jester
a receptionist a waiting room an entire
building and a throne room that is at
the very least some level of influence i
guess they're not even trying to make it
appear that the rancor pit is below the
greats in the floor you can see the sand
directly below the decorative pretend
tiles i am north appeal i am a water
monger in the workers district i'd give
all the sins back if we were to discover
that lortha is a long-lost relative of
jimmy james in news radio is in fact in
the star wars universe this is the first
i'm hearing of it considering today is
also the first day you were debriefed
about the power vacuum this is not
surprising rid the streets of moses this
scourge and i will double my tribute to
him bribery you better fight as good as
you talk dang
i don't know right that's a terrible way
to hire someone hey you talk sassy and
look badassy so i'm gonna hire you
without knowing anything about your
actual skill set wait how did the water
guy even hear fed from all the way over
there in the first place if you're gonna
have all these multicolored most vespas
these things better voltron or mighty
morphin before this episode is over if
not i'm giving it 50 cents
the circle of life also creatures
belching is never funny i mean unless it
is but here it's not we now return you
to the liquid submersion sleepy bubble
chamber of exposition where dreams are
already in progress i am so annoyed by
this clip that i continue to see and yet
do not understand its significance i'm
gonna assume they never properly tell me
why this moment is so important and i'll
give a few sins now and then forget to
give them back later because well sin
count doesn't actually matter unlike
plot points that we've seen many times
that clearly do and should have been
explained by now
well that's just depressing also putting
your hand on the window which causes
hand prints which then need to be
cleaned i just want to say that if you
think this banth is on for some time
just hold tight because they actually
show phet walk back across the desert
too also since the tuscan have several
speeder bikes now as seen in the
previous episode why isn't boba riding
one of those instead of this slow-moving
bantha this miles long bantha hair
hanging off the end of fett's weaponry
yes it's a sin i have business with the
pike syndicate
does boba know what the guard said to
him or is he just guessing from the look
on boba's face i lean the ladder so why
is he just walking on in the guard could
have said you'll need to drink my piss
first saltine crackers do not get that
taste out of your mouth no matter what
your friends might tell you they're so
i've heard please come in and of course
this one speaks english even though the
guard didn't because star wars reasons
the sands have belonged to the tuscan
since the oceans dried and those same
tuscans boba fettered his ass all across
the sands that they owned for days with
no water and just weeks later boba's
doing their bidding does that sound like
the boba fett we saw in two scenes in
the original trilogy i think not show
does not contain a pre-show warning of
no banthas were harmed during the
filming of this episode guess i won't be
needing this anymore also it sure is
lucky for us that boba is having these
dreams of memories in the actual order
that the events occurred ah sudden not
chewbacca and yeah yeah i know he has a
name it's ted what a weird name to give
a wookie you think they come up with
something fun like chrysanthemum missed
opportunity if you ask me i've never
been lifted off my feet by an enraged
wookie but if i were i'd jab my thumbs
into its eye sockets instead of slapping
its thick skull head go for the soft
spots also these two are making a lot of
noise the gladiake is roaring fed is
grunting the regeneration chamber was
opened far too early and must have
sounded an alarm of some kind and yet no
one comes until the in the nick of time
cliche has been activated this
incredibly over flexed big toe
i don't want to be surprised that the
wookie is standing on the perfect spot
to drop into the rancor pit i really do
but i'm not no one is and that is a sin
wasn't it so kind of fat to fetch his
robe before coming down the stairs to
continue to fight off a wookie one might
think he'd also bring a weapon but no
just a robe and a grimace is all fett
needs to command putting your feet on
the table enough food you haven't said
that already i need to respond you need
to get the street kids in here to enjoy
this massive table of food man danny
trejo's cameo appearances just keep
getting weirder and weirder
another twist in turn and who has rights
to what territory oh do go on well i
research when we get back to the far
better bee plot i offer him back if you
renounce all claims to jabba's legacy on
tatooine but
but didn't they just do that
[Music]
but but didn't they just give a rancor
marine corps are emotionally complex
creatures emotions you say skip they can
become very loving loving you say skip
wait we're still in this scene this
rancor is on for some time i've ridden
beast 10 times its size wow that's no
way to talk about your exes i'm not sure
how this gun in her thigh is any more
intimidating than the massive gun on her
back
heavy-handed don't you think the two of
you walked in here all armored up and
once again boba has a [ __ ] gun
heavy-handed was how they entered the
room
it's very hard to take this crayola
crayon kid gang seriously on their
chrome power ranger bikes that only go
15 miles per hour this reminds me of a
joke why didn't the droid cross the road
he didn't have the guts
[Laughter]
[Music]
imagine there being a writer that thinks
of this when they think of star wars and
then imagine someone else giving said
writer a lot of money to work on the
book of boba fett i mean there's zero
reason they would know this in advance
but i still feel like the show missed an
opportunity by not giving sophie
thatcher the yellow speed bike along
with a yellow jacket there's gany
he's working with the pikes i mean of
course he is makes perfect sense that
the exact same group boba's been
dreaming about is who is teaming up with
the mayor to take him down not a
coincidence at all that's just how life
and dreams work but where's my mighty
morphin voltron i want a mighty morphin
voltron i can't tell if these are dreams
or thoughts if they're thoughts then we
know all this actually happened but if
they're dreams then all this bantha
writing is just patting the runtime of
the tv show playing in boba's head these
bones here are actually from the bantha
we saw killed a couple episodes ago
how'd they decompose so quickly well
it's actually because we've been
watching fett stomped through the desert
for over a thousand years
unwanted sexual advances despite being
thrown straight to the back of the
throat mr snuffleupagus manages to
somehow chew this barbecue also this
show maybe use the phrase straight to
the back of the throat in reference to
mr snuffleupagus and it's going to take
a while for me to unpack that cutting
from this campfire scene directly to
boba finding a mortally wounded finnick
makes it seem like this whole sequence
takes place in one night so if you
haven't seen the mandalorian episode
where this all plays out then you don't
know that an entire day has passed and
the finnick has been lying here dying
for a very long time which justifies
boba taking her to mr roboto for
emergency healthcare as opposed to a
licensed physician and since this is all
that took place during the mandalorian
i'm setting everything up into this
point as a previously on which makes
this a record 5 minutes and 38 seconds
of previously awning if i wasn't so
bored i might be impressed choosing
google glass over terminator eyes show
us temporarily derailed by this creepy
exploration of the cyborg gaze
the music that's playing isn't mad about
me and does not contain any figuring or
modal nodes come on disney give the
people what they want someone's
definitely wanting us to compare this
mod parlor to a tattoo parlor but never
explains the implication of a lower back
modification or the function of an upper
back modification aren't you a little
old to be here while aegis i'm more
concerned with the absurdity of this
statement old people are getting modded
all the time we all know at least one
old person that's been pimped out with
metallic joints a partially mechanized
heart and transition lenses this woman
is about to die
well you should have started with that
show wants us to think that services
would not have been rendered had this
undisclosed amount of money not been
dropped on the bench but fett literally
led with she needs modification instead
of saying something like holy sh her
insides are on the outside please
someone help this robotication mods on
for so much of the some time that i
began to question my own dependence on
technology and now i wonder if i'm
already a cyborg what are the rules does
the tech need to be inside me what if
i'm inside it does driving my car make
me a cyborg i need to know hey you got
some borg in my star
cover all that wars machinery it might
be considerably less beautiful to the
person who's expecting an actual abdomen
above their legs as opposed to a new
branch of cyberdyne industries take the
black melon we'll help you recover or
help her rust finnick just had most of
her innards replaced with pistons and
this war boy is offering aquacola
instead of guzzling
throwing shade at bubble tea help me
recover my fire spray gunship seems safe
to assume that the creators don't want
to use the name of boba's ship here and
i get and respect this decision but that
doesn't excuse trying to flex on fenic
by name dropping the make and model of
this thing like the last time my ship
got towed i didn't call my friend larry
and say i need a ride to bail out my
toyota prius if the ship is yours
why don't you just ask for it back of
course i might not like the answer this
response does not preclude the
possibility of asking first then if you
don't like the answer you can proceed
with your planned boba branded bloodbath
with no instructions the surveillance
drone knows immediately where to go in
which building it needs to take
measurements of well i love all the
droids in this franchise especially that
incorrigible bb-8 overly convenient tech
is really doing most of the heavy
lifting in the whole star wars days of
the futuristic past aesthetic
i feel like the spy ball would have had
a much better time hiding if it didn't
insist on chirping away to itself and
wasn't covered in red lights that served
no purpose other than to be something
interesting for us to look at find other
benthas make baby benthus boba doesn't
even consider that a bantha might want
to focus on their career i'm tired of
working for idiots who are going to get
me killed my reaction to reading another
questionable script from the new tv sins
writer somehow makes it into the episode
people like us
don't get to decide when we're finished
badass loner statement based on no
empirical evidence whatsoever cliche i'm
going to take a guess there on a huge
amount of these convenient greats so why
wouldn't one of these few hundred guards
be oh i don't know guarding it sure one
guard will make a difference against
these two but better than leaving it
totally exposed making these cuts closer
to the rock would have prevented these
jagged barons from making their entrance
so gosh darn unsafe whoever put this
scene together thought it was funny to
have the rat catcher singe its poor
little robo taint running through a fire
pit in a desperate attempt to escape a
murderous boba fett the sin here is
failure to mind the gap
[Applause]
[Music]
this show man and veers so hard from
dune-like space hopper into wallace and
grommet-esque shenanigans in the space
of minutes and that would be kind of
cool if i thought for even a second it
was remotely intentional pew pews pew
pews pew pews
excitement what is this droid why does
it explode so readily and if someone
knew that this thing would blow up from
one shot why wouldn't you program it to
avoid crossfire instead of walking
directly into it what the hell are you
doing we need to get the gate open but i
can't see a thing it's almost as if the
designer of the ship was going for
something cool and marketable instead of
anything resembling a practical flying
machine hmm disney i gotta close the
ramp finicthing goes on to do a sick
flip throw thing to this baddie and then
hops inside with just enough time to
make this shot and scowl at the camera
as the door closes all of which was very
cool but in no way required the ramp to
be closed immediately all this did was
open up the possibility of having to
awkwardly ask boba to reopen the ramp if
she missed this shot of boba fett taking
revenge on this speeder bike gang is all
the cool and maybe one of the best uses
of a dutch angle i've ever seen but also
multiple murders putting your fire spray
gunship this close to the desert
sphincter damn it
i can't see a thing being surprised you
can't see a thing when you're the one
who just blocked all the light fire in
the hall this works slash they survived
this because there is no forcing way
that finnick knew the exploding mcguffin
would choose to propel itself out of
this opening once the hatch was opened
and fall off the ship and continue to
fall into the sarlacc maw and then be
eaten by the munchie sphincter this is a
[ __ ] convenience on top of a
contrivance wrapped in a blanket of
unbelievable good fortune how many times
have you been hired to do a job that was
avoidable
if they only took the time to think then
you and i would be out of work hey us
too congratulations master vet
you are completely healed what about the
scars on the inside with all due respect
to the drama boba's experienced we were
all thinking what about the scars on his
face sure it'd been kind of cruel
finnick to say that but she's a former
assassin and he's a former bounty hunter
these are cruel people or at least have
claimed the experience on their resumes
the discount gorham seriously tried this
knowing full well it had nothing to
follow up with other than a look of fear
and the knowledge that he can probably
get replacement limbs at the local mod
shop you were a legend
in the name chrysanton drew crowds by
the thousands wow this exposition about
ted's past really drew me in apparently
it really drew boba fett in to the
building because other than acquiring
this information the show hasn't given
any reason for him to be here right now
hit it max
we've had a veritable plethora of exotic
names like flip finnick garfila
ted and lorth appeal one of these two is
just called [ __ ] max jabba the hutt
once sat upon that throne and then
that fortuna took his place as someone
who regularly watches shows out of order
i refuse to be tamed i get that this
backstory delivered through exposition
can be helpful for people not familiar
with the broader franchise but that
doesn't make it okay it just means i'm
complicit so we both get a sin also this
show's really testing my ability to
suspend disbelief on anyone seriously
using the name bib for tuna putting your
hat on the dinner table what prevents us
all from killing you and taking what we
want
whoever said raincourse didn't have a
sense of dramatic timing was well
actually they were spot on because
there's no way he knew to growl at this
exact moment for maximum intimidation
you fat for smuggling looking like you
had that rehearsed i see you they all
appear to have parked a hundred yards
away i don't know if boba told them to
or they've all got step counters and are
trying to get that 10k in but this seems
foolish when you consider the size of
this garage i mean at least pull up to
the door credits can buy muscle
if you know where to look finnick is
essentially saying that you can buy
something if you know where to go buy it
never have truer words been spoken but
they are not foolish enough to see that
the pikes would eventually take over the
whole planner apparently i missed this
confusing statement in the last episode
thanks for the assist previously on the
more appropriate phrase is they are not
foolish enough to not see that the pikes
will eventually take over the whole
planet so now that's two sins because
it's wrong in two episodes book of mando
you look lost and it looks like you have
your office in a [ __ ] meat locker we
can't all be perfect i can bring you in
warm
or i can bring you in cold this version
of the i can bring you in dead or alive
cliche lacks clarity and could be
misinterpreted as i can bring you in
with or without hot cocoa also biting
someone in a fight is a sin for sure but
is he biting mando's thumb or the gun
because it looks like he's biting the
[ __ ] gun who would even do that even
mike tyson wouldn't do well okay i guess
maybe mike tyson would do that but
surely no one else would i want to
remove one sin for the sheer joy i
experienced at the deployment of this
nightsaber but i also have to add us in
because lucasfilm knows what i want is
giving it to me and i feel dirty also a
non-jedi with no training brings a saber
to a gunfight and it [ __ ] works
despite witnessing the failure of his
co-workers as they just attempted the
same thing caba baez shoots the heavily
armored individual in the armor to no
effect mando is a dick to tables show
deprives me of seeing this structure in
its entirety i've got so many questions
like why does the ring have a gap is it
still under construction is this part of
the space zoned for multi-family
residential staring at someone on an
elevator elevator rides with other
people are awkward enough don't make it
weirder learn the etiquette part of me
is loving this entire sequence but the
other part of me feels like i ordered a
book of boba fett sandwich so far all
i'm getting is a slathering of the
mandalorian a few slices of halo and now
a sprinkling of mass effect just saying
where's the bob
[Music]
only one platter in two sides of these
orange balls no one wants to touch this
hardly looks like a feast and it also
looks like everyone's finished eating
already so this is really just an
invitation to attempt a conversation
while being the only person at the table
eating we all know this just ends with
people watching you chew and you feeling
weird about it
being willing to sit calmly in feast
when someone sets a decapitated head on
the table i don't care if that shit's in
a bag it still smells like a decapitated
head it's really unfortunate this leg
injury didn't happen earlier in the year
mandalorian insurance isn't great but
it's better than nothing however when
you get in that donut hole it's very
hard to get out am i right based on the
average age of our viewers i'm guessing
most of you will understand this joke in
about 40 years all this talk of the
empire and they lasted less than 30
years
mandalorians have existed 10 000. in the
first 12 minutes of this episode has
felt like at least 15 years so your
point is what exactly also history
lessons i am told it is the dark saber
this blade's position goes on for some
time just to give us a bunch of metrics
by which we're supposed to determine
whether mando is or is not the one
whoever wields it
can lead all of mandalore if it is won
by creed in battle i mean i haven't seen
michael b jordan in this episode but i
guess he could be showing up later seems
more likely at this point than boba fett
showing up mandalore will be laid to
waste and its people scattered to the
four winds later the show goes on to
describe events that make it sound like
mandalore has already been laid to waste
so it kind of seems like it doesn't
matter who has this thing anymore death
would have been justice for his
atrocities
this is true
the armorer is that friend that shows up
after you've moved all the heavy pieces
of furniture so you're hanging out with
all these tools in the previous scene
put them back in are now whipping them
out again and the forge wasn't even
operational it can also pierce basker
armor
its mere existence puts mandalorians at
risk these mandalorians really like
talking shop about singular weapons
maybe if they thought big picture they'd
still have a planet those born of
mandalore strayed away from the path
this footage makes it look less like
they strayed from the path and more like
the path was obliterated by suborbital
bombardment discount war of the machines
only those that walked the way escaped
the curse prophesied in the creed
seriously did disney buy the rocky
franchise or something because if you're
telling me the rocky movies are now
connected with star wars i have become
at least two percent more interested in
this episode i've also become seven
percent less interested math was never
my strong suit also this prophecy talk
prophesizes for all the some time what
shall i forge for the foundling
grogu a better name
she hammers the end of the spear a few
times and then quenches it and voila we
have tiny metal rings whoever thought
that we wouldn't be more interested in
this entire process has completely
overlooked the success of forged in fire
also the suggestion here is that this
will be some sort of chain mail but we
aren't even allowed to see the finished
product yet and i don't like being frock
teased i am focused
the blade says otherwise blades can't
talk it was forged by my ancestor
founder of house vista then why didn't
you bring this up earlier this future
fight feels forced and filler-esque in
fact let's just give it 25 cents here
because while i'm always happy to see
mando this entire episode seems like a
desperate attempt to force fetus a new
mandalorian episode so people would keep
watching boba fett minus the boba and
the fat
dinjarin
have you ever removed your helmet the
mandalorians sure do like rules i guess
i get that it's just that this helmet
check really derails the momentum of
this scene it's like someone whipped out
a challenge coin i'm sorry sir you can't
board a commercial flight with your
weapons no one will be seated while
mando goes through a tsa checkpoint
kids when you miss someone you see them
everywhere you look cliche wally's
cousin pops up on screen don't get me
wrong i always love meeting a new member
of the family but disney you're getting
very close to creating a cute and
lovable droid cliche also creating a
cute and lovable droid to tear my heart
out when it gets eaten by a predatory
animal also also why is a predatory
animal trying to eat a robot there's
gotta be so little nutritional value in
those things what is she even shooting
at the creature's gone behind the engine
block she's just wasting ammo and pelly
doesn't strike me as someone who would
be wasting ammo you can't say no you're
a droid indentured servotude show goes
down the route of making spaceships seem
to have the same complexity as muscle
cars suggesting that anyone with enough
gumption can repair or rebuild one don't
worry about the shape and size just get
the parts you want the specs you need
and i'm gonna make it work all right i
dated a jaw i don't see how your dating
record makes you more or less qualified
to modify spaceship parts detail that
seems lost on the mandalorian a literal
and metaphorical indication of disney's
desire to shove weird creatures into
every orifice of this franchise sparks
equal fixing you hit this button you're
gonna evacuate your exhaust manifold if
you know what i mean title of my sex
tape ever since they've been moving
spice to the system everything's gone to
hell i'm not concerned with the obvious
comparisons to dune the problem here is
that my imagination immediately puts the
two franchises in the same universe and
i can't decide now if i do or don't want
that to happen the panel that had mando
all confused before is no longer on the
ship that's a lot of engine for a little
ship it's also the wrong engine noise
for a spaceship i think they put a
little too much internal combustion in
their j-type pulse engines these flight
maneuvers around this ship look really
awesome and do give the space police a
reason to pull him over but this seems
reckless and oddly out of character
fermando are we reporting this
you want to go back to base fill out
reports all day even in a galaxy far far
away excessive paperwork is the hurdle
between doing and not doing your job
those j type pulse engines really
tighten the old evacuation port don't
they show takes a second shot at this
excretion joke and now i'm left
wondering if there is a meaningful
difference between the exhaust manifold
and the evacuation port tell them it's
on the house but first
i gotta pay a visit to a little friend i
usually don't care for these spin-off
episodes but i really enjoyed this
character i hope he gets his own show i
gotta know who that little guy is
uh no
there we go
there's a job title on tatooine master
squeakums and that person's job is to
climb up and lube these whirly giggers
that person's currently doing a terrible
job which is why the whirly gigger
council is currently attempting to rally
a political rival to rise in the ranks
of the maintenance guild and usurp
master squeekums this by the way is a
much more interesting plot than whatever
boba fett is trying to do it's all there
we'll leave the spice and take the
credits back
do you know where you are gentlemen
arrakis they get through they shouldn't
have to think about it too much there's
three of them and one of him i mean i
know justified over there could probably
take out all four of the pikes before
they could get a shot off but they don't
know that now load that chest and go
considered a fine for trespassing
stealing we all wanted to see the gun
shoot and run tootin feller flip his
weapon into his holster but is now the
best time the enemy isn't gone and you
just lost any advantage of having your
gun drawn and ready to shoot the pattern
on this shirt was born from boredom a
ruler and a sharp set of spurs tell me
i'm wrong this spice is precious and
illegal so why put it in a box that can
easily be flipped open with the toe of a
boot i see we're still on a mandalorian
side quest and yes i've heard the fan
excuses of this is a mandalorian
spin-off and blah blah blah but here's
the thing even if that is the case i
don't recall an episode of star trek
deep space nine where we spent an
episode and a half with the tng crew and
never saw a single cast member from ds9
and if you want to argue that ds9 isn't
a spin-off of tng then i'll just say i
don't recall an episode of frasier where
we spend an entire episode and a half
with the gang at cheers without a single
frasier cast member in sight i've got
all day and a useless amount of spin-off
tv knowledge do you it's nice to see
that even with these mandalorian assigns
the show hasn't forgotten its main focus
countless scenes of characters walking
anyone alive we've been watching these
ant droids build a dome for a solid two
minutes no none of the audience is alive
anymore oh look groga is distracted by a
frog cliche new cliches are so cute when
they're young force-feeding a child i
appreciate that booker bob is trying to
explain the frog reigning scene in
magnolia but let's face facts that will
never make sense and also i'm ready to
get back to boba fett doing wait what is
it exactly that he's doing on this show
seriously what is this show also the
issue with this moment is that skywalker
is trying to save focus and i will teach
you how to use more power but the
message grogu receives is very likely
more power equals frog buffet i want to
tell you about someone you remind me of
a great deal
his name was yoda
he was small like you he was also the
same [ __ ] species but for some reason
creepy looking young luke is leaving
that little factoid out why creepy luke
why luke appears to be moving grogu
forward so that he can keep up the
walking pace isn't that a bit of a dick
move let the kid walk in his own way why
force him to move forward because you
aren't willing to slow down force you
luke i mean it funny size matters not
luke quoting yoda quoting my ex-college
girlfriend feels really strange in this
show do you remember back home i don't
know the exact amount of time grogu's
been hanging out with luke but it's
definitely been long enough to where i'm
not buying this is the first time luke
has asked this question the galaxy is a
dangerous place grogu especially when
your name's grogu there's no kid that
could live that name down you
i didn't expect to see you here i didn't
expect to see any of you here but here
we are on the boba fett and friends
variety hour then what are you doing
here fan service duh there's nothing now
but will someday be a great school and
by someday they mean later in this
episode we're not sure exactly how much
time has passed because unlike other
sci-fi shows they're giving us zero
stardate indications
mando is a dick to grogu
really
that's all you got shaming a child for
jumping like a child come on i want to
show you something i mean sure interrupt
the kids attempted for sleeping and
spend the next few minutes showing off
your own abilities i'm here at the
request of fennec shand and that's all
you need to know to trust my intention
implicitly sure there's a war about to
break out and the card was clearly
concerned with my arrival but that's
okay as long as you know that i know
fenix name we're all good bone-headed
hood ornaments
we now interrupt this episode of jedi
training academy interrupting this
episode of the mandalorian interrupting
this episode of boba fett for an episode
of cobb vance space marshall
where's the little guy
back with his own folk
that's too bad
i guess we both lost something we were
fond of comparing the loss of body armor
to the loss of as close to his son as
amanda will probably ever have holy [ __ ]
this episode also has a mandalorian
walks into a bar cliche we're playing
all the hits today i love the idea that
these bones are from the dragon that was
slain but how long ago was that did the
whole town pitch together to pick all
the meat from the bone did they leave it
in the desert long enough for it not to
reek i'm sorry i didn't catch your name
i will give every sin back on my entire
channel if this guy says twinkleberry
blue howdy howdy howdy i mean why wear
bullets around your ankles that seems
like a very dangerous place that would
be jarred and bumped often not to
mention it's the furthest distance from
the gun you'd need to reload it's pretty
annoying that the first resemblance of
what i would consider to be a great
scene in this series takes place with
less than 10 minutes left in the
penultimate episode of the season and
because this is just going to be a
record that keeps on repeating it
doesn't include boba fett
fat i guess everyone wants to make sure
cobb is alright which makes sense but
they skip right over the deputy who is
well dead but do they know that can we
take your helmets for a cleaning i think
of all the characters in this series
these are the two i feel the worst for
they have one [ __ ] job and no one
will let them do it let them clean your
helmets
but wait you forgot your cap so star
wars is just the godfather now really
looking forward to boba waking up with a
bantha head in his bed i guess it's kind
of nice we're not just ripping off
kurosawa anymore
omg that body armor is just i can't
resist it any longer remove a sin now
before i change my mind but you may
choose only one luke skywalker is the
party pooper of the star wars universe
which do you choose frogs he chooses
frogs one minute and 40 seconds of being
treated like drew barrymore in 50 first
dates
wasn't this club filled with people
either that bomb was very efficient or
the rubble to corpse ratio seems a
little off here it was inevitable well
actually it wasn't inevitable was it you
could have left dooney world at any
point but you seem pretty set on playing
boba father and that directly led to
these lovely people being vaporized also
who's this guy again he's been holding
off the spice trade single-handedly i
told him we could shut it down
that's not free finnick might be wasted
in this show but she would be excellent
at tv since marcespa can become a
prosperous city under our protection are
we counting garcia's business no putting
that behind us then are track records
pristine let marshall vantan the people
of moss belgium freetown is its name now
did mando mommy not teach you good
manners let your elder talk
if you want to abandon maas espen hide
in your fortress go ahead
we're staying
the people who live here need our
protection which is screenwriter code
for jabba's palace is a bit too op and
we need the audience to think bob
domanda fed are actually at risk was
your venture successful
you won't have to worry about freetown
nice work mr bane i mean that response
was vaguer than i'd hoped but i'm gonna
trust you dealt with the whole of
freetown and not just their sheriff you
know so there's no chance they ex
machina this [ __ ] at the last second i
didn't realize the pike syndicate was so
ruthless pragmatic
they were charging us protection
justifying tribal displacement what's an
x-wing doing here fan service would be
my first guess closely followed by they
couldn't afford to cgi a star destroyer
and luke skywalker
choosing man daddy over luke and yoda's
freaking lightsaber is sin
[Music]
i know an astromech blew the ship good
as long as you know that and we know
that we can all go on happily knowing
that we know all the things that need to
be known to enjoy grogu's convenient
arrival in the finale the mandalorian
roll commercials
i said what i said bring him some dumb
worms i know grogu has eaten many
questionable things but poo parasites is
where i drama
line
[Music]
oh keep your dome on considering how
powerless r2 is to prevent peli from
taking grosgu here i have to wonder why
luke thought it was a good idea what if
this had been literally anyone else on
tatooine synchronized captain morganing
chrysanton is in trandocion territory i
think finnick needs to brush up on her
wikipedia knowledge this is an absolute
liability but i guess one-armed
transitions are about to become all the
rage all our flanks are covered nobody
is sneaking up on us finnick is basing
this on having two pig people at the
starport a few teen terminators
wandering the streets and ted patrolling
town hall covered this isn't even a
light dusting gamora and nipples have
better coverage than this when the
people of freetown arrive we will have
the forces required to pivot our
strength to whatever region the pikes
choose to attack from another bold claim
considering you don't actually know that
the freetonians are coming or if they do
how many they'll actually number what if
it's only oh i don't know 10 people and
a hovercraft
slow cowboy eye contact reveal cliche i
thought i smelled something can you
smell while wearing that helmet either
cadbane smells a fresh bantha fodder and
gym socks or bobas trying to diminish
his morale regardless both of these
things smell of bad etiquette if that's
not the quack to call in the stiffling
slimy yeah well i'm rubber and you're
forgetting that i don't have the
necessary context to understand the damn
thing you just said before you get any
ideas
i've got back shooters too indeed he
does but what he doesn't have is a
helmet so i don't know why fennec and
mano don't blast demon cowboy crazy frog
while they still have a chance sure
their armor can take a few hits in the
meantime you mean the one that massacred
your tuscan family and blamed it on a
speedlike gang which means that boba
murdered the gang for a crime they
didn't commit yes they were by no means
good guys but maybe you should gather a
bit more information than a suspiciously
obvious gang tag before dispensing your
pew pews of justice why aren't the mods
shooting first you have time to make
comps to your allies but have no time to
shoot them based on your observation the
mods watching all these aliens take
their time fumbling with weapons they
barely know how to use tells me the
judgment is not the mod strong suit i
thought we had a treaty
so did i a treaty you barely had a
gentleman's agreement did boba seriously
not think this betrayal was likely or
even possible i once trusted my dad when
he said he would trade me boardwalk but
i still came prepared to flip that
monopoly board the second he betrayed me
admiral ackbar did it better homeless
panic and worry from the civilians
except for this lady who is all for this
chaos i'm still stunned that any amount
of responsibility was entrusted with the
two individuals who have just allowed
themselves to be herded off a cliff edge
anything even running straight at their
enemies would have been better than
relying on a sudden resistance to
gravity i hope she gets there in 40
minutes to end this war would be
terrible if she got caught in traffic or
god forbid a one-sided gun fight
hold up nobody heard the speeder's
approach it was right next to the mods
an aqualish gun fight finnick pulled up
dismounted climbed the building and made
herself comfortable to shoot the enemy
all without being seen or heard i get
that she's a master assassin but the
people of tatooine are oblivious to a
fault manners
i like it unless she's vocalizing
through her nostrils this minimal mask
lowering was pretty pointless they're
here
it was just a matter of time indeed it
was so why are you still here the idea
was to protect the people of mos espa
but since your plan has gone out of the
airlock aren't they better served by
drawing the pikes back to the more
defensible palace and away from all the
civilian homes also i'm no bounty hunter
but you already had one visitor don't
you think it might be better to move
around a little so you're not in an
already known place maybe a flanking
position or up high on the rooftops feel
like this is bounty hunting 101. all
three gotchas of my sister turned on us
putting trust into crime lords yeah they
got your good
[Laughter]
i have no compunction whatsoever
genuflecting or even groveling if needs
be what about any veneration of sequence
or general sycophancy that might be
needed say i have a thesaurus too and it
doesn't make me any less annoying either
read it to me tail head and it's racist
visual definition of getting kneecapped
also why does boba's built-in arsenal
only function along the y-axis the
badasses with jetpacks choose this
position instead of any of the widely
available high ground you don't have to
like episode 3 to acknowledge the
lessons it teaches why are 12 people
hiding behind this one tank there's more
coverage to your left and right i do
believe you can die with honor if it's
not done with stupidity
18 people hiding behind the tank
probably won't be shot today why did
they wait till after they turned the
corner to turn their shields on doesn't
appear to affect their maneuverability
so why risk deploying them at the last
possible second it's almost as if they
knew the baubalorian crew had no
intention of firing at them yet also why
weren't the bobolarian crew firing at
them yet they think there was a chance
this wasn't going to end in a fire fight
did they think they were on the same
team
honestly i wonder why disney didn't save
us all some time and just titled the
whole damn show everything wrong with
boba fett i'm really not needed here ted
faking your previous injuries is no way
to go about war also i'm not sure why
anybody is bothering to run away as
deadly as these things look they
apparently can't aim lower than a
two-story house the darksaber the most
badass weapon in the galaxy right up
until the plot deems it to be too
powerful and renders it useless we'll
just store that away with the infinity
stones mjolnir in the incredible hulk
anyone else seeing a pattern here a 360
no
[Music]
scope feel like she's every npc i've
ever come across in a video game who
still has their shop open and great
crisis i know hell incarnates outside
but i'm gonna still smile through it all
because ignorance is bliss and i have
something i want to give to you turn
around can't hear you i understand her
not being able to hear mando over the
sound of all the laser fire and stomping
scorpio bots but shouldn't the laser
fire and stomping scorpio bots been clue
enough that this is not a safe place for
her and grosgu also what the [ __ ] is r2
doing right now
oh
okay little guy
i'm happy to see you too oh
two sins all for the most adorable force
hug in the galaxy the spindle board
decides to stop attacking just long
enough for the rancor and fed to have
their dramatic entrance what a
thoughtful piece of programming
okay i officially have no forcing clue
how this shield works i assumed it was
just projected outward from the droid
but the rancor pummeling actually knocks
it over which means the shield is
somehow physically connected to the
equilibrium of the droid itself why why
would you design a shield to be so
specifically weak against a kinetic
attack
[Music]
why does mando wait until after the
rancor has been shot again to dark saber
some sh when you get the chance to dark
saber you dark saber dude huh well now
that i've seen the dark saver slice
through one piece of the droid like a
hot knife through butter but struggle to
penetrate with a stab to the brain
perhaps mando is right to avoid using
this confusing weapon at all why is
mando's jetpack always set to make me
look like a badass instead of zoom me
out of danger when i really need it i'll
distract the droid wouldn't distracting
the droid work better if you were more
than two feet away from the person
you're distracting it from so earlier on
when boba said these two will destroy
the whole city he was just mad that he
wasn't getting in on the destruction fun
too
jet pack
but i have armor
let's find out can
he not see
the armor
consider this my final lesson look out
for yourself
anything else
is weakness giving life advice to
someone you're about to murder boba
assumes this single stab to the chest
has killed cat bane this is especially
complacent considering how much insanely
unsurvivable [ __ ] we know that boba has
survived will anybody ever go for the
head why does it seem to be baked into
every mega monster's jeans to climb the
tallest tower and be as cinematic as
possible waiting 50 minutes for
something that takes all of one minute
to do i'm really trying to think of a
single situation where a bipedal droid
makes sense on a desert planet is it
just to give people something to laugh
at why does it have to be the right arm
well because if it was a left arm it
feels like a stranger was doing it i
prefer for these things to feel personal
we are not suited for this then what the
[ __ ] of the last seven episodes been
about
no
kids i have to hope at least one person
on the boat team was like hey isn't it a
bit shitty the fans of the mandalorian
are going to be confused as the start of
season three do we really have to force
them to watch every second of content in
order to keep up of course any further
protest would have been met with a swift
force choke by a hooded figure with
dimly lit mouse-like features as it
rasps in disgust this is the way
[Music]
you've just been erased have you ever
had a dream neo that you were so sure
was real panned down from the twin sons
of tatooine uh we are now close on the
mouth of the sarlacc pit after a beat
the gloved mandalorian armor gauntlet of
boba fett
grabs onto the sand outside the sarlacc
pit and the feared bounty hunter pulls
himself from the maw of the sand beast
when cameron was in egypt's land
[Music]
randy lay there like a slug it was his
only defense so you bring no tribute i
volunteer as tribute
the mayor's heart felt welcome and
regrets that he's been drawn away by
pressing matters milady what the [ __ ]
did you call me would you care to
partake in any of our sundry offerings
maybe another time
i'm here to talk business i didn't know
you were such a ballet fan i thought you
just liked it in private
your helmet is so big
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
am i devious yes i think i am but as the
old saying goes i didn't come here to
make friends
[Music]
want some bacon
no man i don't eat pork
are you jewish no i ain't jewish i just
don't dig on swine that's all why not
pigs are filthy animals i don't eat
filthy animals
[Music]
oh my god david what are you doing i'm
teaching him how to ride a bike oh
please don't you know i can't stand the
sight of blood ah sears like tuna stinks
all i want is to fight on the top of a
train it's not right you think you could
do these things but you just can't no
disassemble where are you going
i'm here to see the mayor
you don't have an appointment do you
well we didn't know how to make one
appointment for what what do you want we
need some help cool
we have a cooler leak everybody let's go
let's get out of here everybody out
let's move and here you see the
businesses that were under the
protection of
the name that should not be spoken you
can say jabba we do
[Music]
you want me to ask around i don't know
what the hell you're talking about lucy
and i want you to shut up
state your name and your business but mr
lumber told me to talk to payroll and
then payroll told me to talk to mr
lumberg and i still haven't received my
paycheck and he took my stapler
that's gonna leave a mark
done
work on water
here you go
well i'm not gonna let my meatball get
away from me this time
we are bored
please kind sir do not cut my hair
what's the best i could do under the
circumstances sucks to be you nerd
what the hell are you doing
i have no idea what i'm doing but i know
i'm doing it really really well
500
i can offer you something no client ever
has
what's that
forced
laughing
good tea nice house what's wrong dude
you yell
nobody
calls me yellow
i
[Music]
well looks like you finally got your
crossover episode
and in my club i will splash the pot
whenever the
i please
[Music]
[Music]
what do you know of this blade
this
toasts
bread
while you're slicing it
the blade says otherwise
for this test sir
it will not kill
i have
then you are a mandalorian no more
yeah i got the memo and i understand the
policy and the problem is just that i
forgot the one time and i've already
taken care of it so it's not even really
a problem anymore
what a piece of sh
ever since they've been moving spice to
the system everything's gone to hell
human sacrifice dogs and cats living
together mass hysteria
now this is pod racing
how's the handling man this baby must
corner like it's on
rails tell them it's on the house
but first
i gotta pay a visit to a little friend
shout out to my new friend
do you know where you are gentlemen
i'll kill for you before you even clear
your weapons i can see you're the smart
one i tried to imagine a fellow smarter
than myself and then i tried to think
what would he do i'm looking for
skywalker take me to your leader i
didn't expect to see you here nobody is
ready for oscar
and who might you be when a man with a
45 meets a man with a rifle you said the
man with a pistol is a dead man let's
see if that's
tell them i'm true
and hell's coming with me you hear
my car
extreme
tell your master this the armies of
mordor must disband he is to depart
these lands never to return oh
old graveyard
i have a token i was bitten to show thee
back in the pile back in the pile
everyone we're going back to the pipes
now we're going back
[Music]
it's up in the pocket he'll fire to the
right side called by diggs stay oh my
god
[Applause]
[Music]
what's your angle my god how can you be
so obtuse what did you call me
i've never seen anything like this
before
seeing cora how impressive was that
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser